hey it's antique a chair and this type
of Tuesday video we're not gonna be
looking at this week's data set I'm
gonna continue working on some tidy
model stuff and this case we're actually
gonna go on to this new data set called
the Palmer penguins and the main idea is
to basically use this toy data set
that's an alternative to the famous IRS
data set so I thought it would be
interesting to basically make some
models for using the tidy models
framework and kind of go through all the
main packages of the tiny models and
kind of just explain the main functions
for each package additionally I think
it'd be kind of cool to actually deploy
a tidy model into a shiny app so that's
what we're gonna do this week so we're
just going to use the plumber Penguins
and the Talia models package okay so
we're gonna load up a markdown file our
markdown and it'll say tidy Tuesday
deploying will say tidy Tuesday penguin
model cool all we're gonna pop that up
do with this stuff so we're gonna use
the title verse the tidy models package
and also the palmer penguins package and
you can install the palmer penguins
package by just using the remotes
install function install github function
because it's a private not private a
public repository okay so we have that
and the palmer penguins package just
comes with two data sets which is
penguins cool so let's just do a basic
EDA we're gonna look at the Penguins um
one thing that I think would be
interesting is just to predict species
I'm using you know the island origin
build links build up you know basic um
basic on descriptions of the actual
penguin so its first count the species
and we can see that first of all there's
three different classes
and the classes are a little bit
imbalance where actually we don't have a
lot of chinstrap um species so we kind
of tit a 10-count if when I do any type
of sample procedures to rebalance the
class the classes that we're trying to
predict
okay so species has some imbalances cool
additionally if we will cut right here
we can see that there's actually some na
s so if we do a Penguin's summary we can
see that there's a decent amount of na
so you know there's like two two two two
eleven so I'm missing a decent mount
compared to all the columns we're
actually missing a decent honest values
from the sex column additionally I what
I want to do is I want to look at UM row
wise missing numbers missing values so
if a row is missing say like the
majority of its values and we may want
to remove it so I'm gonna do this
penguins mutate row num equals row
number and I'll do eight gather K equals
key value equals value mine - row no
right and then I'll do a filter or value
is n a and then lastly I'll just do a
count of the rhone um sort Eccles true
okay so what we have here we actually
have two rows that are missing five
values
and if we look at it we have one two
three four five six seven values so that
is a lot of values that it's missing and
I think that we should actually remove
that okay so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna do a slice one to two and
then select row num so these are the row
numbers we want to remove so I'm going
to say rows to remove okay and now I'm
going to remove the rows
so I'm gonna do this first so say check
um how many n A's or each row and then
I'll say remove rows that have too many
anaise okay so I'm going to do the same
thing just to do a do that and then I'll
do a anti join with fros to remove I
equals row and now we are we aren't
missing those now we removed any roads
that we're missing more than five
oops 5 5 n A's right because we had 4
and 24 and now we can see where we don't
have the 4 or 24 anymore
ok so then I'll say deselect the minus
row numb and I'll apply it to the
Penguins again ok so we did it some
basic data cleaning and now let's
actually look at the na s for each each
column okay so we'll do that again say
check column n A's and we see that we
actually are we actually removed most of
our n A's and now it's only just um sex
cool
so one thing that we kinda have to think
about is okay so if we have sex as our
only missing values um what's let's
figure out how we should impute it
because it's actually um the class
imbalance its class balance for sex is
pretty pretty even so let's see if we
can find anything that's predictable um
one thing that I was thinking about is
we can't really use mode for these
categorical variables however one thing
that we could do is maybe a K nearest
neighbor
so that's we're gonna do we're gonna do
a select when do maybe a pivot longer
and then we'll say yeah we'll just do a
gather key equals key value equals value
minus sex and then I'll just say select
minus species and - island okay
and then I'll do it GTA s x equals sex y
equals value was genome box plots plus
facet wrap my key scales pools free and
then we'll do a how about we go color
ego sex color equals sex so what we see
here is we actually see that the the
flip these numerical features actually
show a difference between genders just
some basic implications is that men or
male penguins are generally larger which
that makes sense we can also figure out
maybe like species in island so instead
of doing we can instead of doing yeah
instead of doing so - between say minus
species and - island and then we could
say you know let's do is X equal species
so we can see it kind of cross tabs
between species insects how you know
some species will be larger with bill
depth some will have a longer bill
length etc but we can see the basic
pattern that males are generally larger
in sizes Orient's in these um features
than females okay so we can say this a
male and female have different sizes and
features can probably impute missing
with kanan okay cool so now let's just
do let's look at the distributions just
say examine distributions and that's
something where we'll take the Penguins
will say select I don't know bill
length - body mass and then we'll just
do a pivot longer Oh actually we'll just
do a gap well just do it gather and then
gather and then we can just do a ggplot
x equals value color equals key plus
density plus facet wrap key scales
equals three okay and we see these
distributions they are all though that
they're not normal distributions there
you can see this like bimodal sums are
skewed right so we might have to do some
scaling Senate scaling stuff like that
okay so exam distributions probably need
to Center
and scale but nothing looks too crazy
where we would I wouldn't really want to
go too crazy with like estimating other
distributions and stuff like that okay
so when we go back to the title models
package the first package that's the
most important and you'll use in a tidy
models framework is the our sample
package so we're gonna show the our
sample package so our sample package
example so this main package is
basically for like sampling procedures
and the main thing that you'll kind of
do with it is the split function so what
first-world will split our data so tight
you split initial sweat penguins and
prop equals point eight so we'll do an
80/20 split and then our sample also
comes with a training function that uses
the split and a testing function and
this will create our training test sets
so we'll say Tidy train training tidy
split and then tidy heat test testing
tidy split so says so first we're gonna
say create the train and test sets using
our sample
additionally we can also specify how we
can do our tuning procedures so we can
do K folds so we can do tidy K folds
which is V fold TV and in this case
we're gonna give it our training day set
we can also do something instead of
using K folds we can also use say w1 out
method we've went out cross-validation
we also do uh was it bootstrap yeah we
can do bootstrapped so there's different
type of of sampling procedures you can
do when you're tuning your model but in
this case I'm just gonna use the K pols
cross-validation okay cool actually I'll
do uh I'll do a what set seed 42 okay so
we got that okay so the next package
that we're really gonna be looking at
and this is kind of the fact that it has
a lot of the the main meat and potatoes
in it is the recipes package and this is
for basic pre-processing so just I'm
gonna just show you how to the main
functions of the rescue package recipes
package and this for pre-processing for
data-feature engineering and even
feature a limit lemonnation um if you
see my past videos we actually have done
a decent feature engineering
specifically if with like interaction
effects however in this case what we're
gonna do is mostly with the
pre-processing function so we're gonna
call the main commanders the recipe we
specify the the formula in this case
we're gonna be predicting species with
all of our data and then we give it our
data in this case we're gonna give it
our tidy train data first we're going to
do with some imputations
and this case we can do step KN and
amputate because we see that the gender
can definitely be imputed using the
other features okay so we'll say we want
to impute the sex column and then what
we want to do is we're going to create
our dummy variables and we'll say all
however aula nominal will also include
this species so we want to also we want
to remove that so we'll say but we don't
want to include any of the outcomes okay
and then what we can do is we can just
say what does impute anything that in
case if there's any missing values and
also normalize all of our values all of
our operators so dummying is basic for
the pre-processing median impute is just
case we have any missing numbers in the
future and then we also do is
normalization for more kind of more
pre-processing well you know I do too
many feature engine we didn't really do
any feature engineering our the this
normalization could be kind of
considered as some type of a future
engineering okay so we do that we can
also do call a prep function to
basically see what it's doing so we
could say okay it's doing cane year's
neighbor amputation for these values its
grained dummy variables for island and
sex and then it's imputing all about
impugning for any of the nominal values
and that does finalize center and
scaling makes sense that's what we
wanted to do okay so we'll call us the
tidy recipe i i've made a ton of videos
on the Rusties package so you can go and
kind of go through my channel and see
more complex recipes usage okay so now
we're gonna actually go to the models
part of the tidy models package so we're
gonna use a parsnip which is basically
the main standardized API for creating
machine learning models okay so we're
gonna say parsnip package and this
basically is the standard standardized
API for creating models in this case
what we're gonna do is if we look at the
tidy models um let's your go to
reference anak basic homes with
different models and what's cool is you
can specify the the type of model so you
say I want a boosted model and you go a
little specify the engine so you say I
want a boosted model that uses a neck
series back-end or I want to use a boost
model that uses spark as it back in in
this case proc gonna use a lucid model
so let's say tie DBC model boost tree
and we go back to it we can see that
there's actually a decent amount of
primers that they give you in this case
I just want it to tune the trees so it's
tree schools tune min n or min samples
is tuned and they'll learn rate which
will be tuned also I want to set the
mode for a classification I'll set the
engine as a XE boost okay also create a
K nearest neighbor model so you is
called nearest neighbor the only primers
is neighbors which will attune that set
them set the mode to classification and
this set the engine to k and k k and
then okay cool so the parson package is
actually not really a complicated
package but then the thing that I think
confuses people the most is actually the
tune and the dials package so the tuna
in the dial is packaged kind of go hand
in hand
the the dial is package which is this
basically kind of does the
standardization for all the tuning
parameters and it allows you to create
basically the grids so given these
models they all have different
parameters so the boost model has trees
min and learn rate or is the K nearest
neighbor model only has neighbors the
tune the dials package really creates
like a grid for you to test these
parameters before the model whereas the
that I mean the dial is creates the grid
or the parameters or is the tune
actually kind of tunes the dial and
actually applies these parameters to the
models to get the best results so we're
gonna use this so will say I'm dials
creates the parameter grids tune applies
the parameter grid to the models
so in this case we're going to use the
dials first titles package so what we
can do is if we actually look up the
parameter so we can say parameters from
the toon package and then and then we
can grab the tidy boosted models
parameters see it so when you say
parameters it'll say okay here are the
parameters that we want to do but we can
also use the grid regular from the but
tiles package so parameters comes from
the toon package and grid regular comes
from the dials package and we can put
the parameters that we want to put in
the grid and we can grab their
parameters from the model and then give
it to the grid and then we can specify
how many um framers want a tune or what
variations do we want to make so in this
case I said 10 I'm going to switch it
off 5 so we have 125 different sets of
parameters that we're going to test for
are our boosted model so I'll say
boosted grid and then we'll do a KN grid
grid regular parameters tidy cannon
model I will say levels equals 10 okay
so that's a dials package and then the
tuned package just applies it in this
case we're actually gonna call the tune
grid and we're gonna give it a model so
tidy boosted model our recipe tidy
recipe our resamples which is our tidy k
folds and lastly our grid which will be
our boosted grid okay and we'll say
we'll call this boost did tune and then
we're also gonna do it to our canaan
model so tune grid are tied a canon
model our idea recipe our resamples
which is our tidy k folds and then our
grid which is our KN bread what I'm
going to do is I'm going
why I'm gonna basically train all these
models using crossed k-fold
cross-validation you can figure out
which of these primers which pair of
parameters in these grids give me the
best results okay so I'm gonna run that
I'm gonna pause the video and I'll
resume it when it finishes training okay
so our models finished training now
we're gonna use the toon package to
actually um select our best metrics so
we can do is we can again do the select
we can grab our tuning so boosted tune
and then select best in this case we can
do say like accuracy or we can also use
ROC a you see let's here are these
actually the same yep so in this case
I'm gonna see you ROC a you see they
actually use since this is a multi-class
classification problem they actually use
a different variation of ROC AOC in this
case they use the hand tail variation
but that's not really a big deal so
we'll just call this the boosted
parameters or boosted per am k and then
we can also do that with our KN tune so
KN REM can tune select best ROC AOC okay
so with this say use tune package to
extract best parameters using ROC AUC
hand tail okay and then what we're gonna
do is apply a parameters to the models
so what we'll do is we'll say we will
use the finalize model give it the tidy
boosting model and our boosted program
and I'll basically give those parameters
into the model okay and then we'll do
the same thing with the KNN model
finalized mono
tidy Canaan model and then Kane and RAM
okay so now that we have all these
finalized models now we're gonna go to
the workflow package and the workflow
package basic kind of centers around
combining everything together okay so
basically applies that pre-processing
the modeling all into one little object
okay so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna create I'll worked well so this is
going to be our busted' workflow
workflow add a model which will be our
tidy recent model and then add our
recipe which would be our tidy wreck
okay sit for combining model parameters
and pre-processing okay and then we'll
say Kanan or foil workflow add model
tidy cannon model add recipe tidy wreck
okay so now that we have our trained
models using all of our training data
which also found the best parameters
what we're gonna do is now we're gonna
put it to the test set so we're actually
to use the last package which is the
toon package and the toon package is say
for extracting metrics from from the
model so this spacing measures how your
model is doing with your data so we're
gonna do that let me call this the boost
it lucid was it results and we'll say
the last fit
boosted workflow and then our tidy split
and then we'll also do the ooh we used
to work for and rest tiny moon tidies
let's see what's going on here
no no jokes just that sorry about that I
don't know why it was running into
errors but so I just said the last fit
and we'll all see that for the K and res
I also changed the things where I was
actually spelling the boosted model
wrong but I fixed that so you guys
shouldn't have any problems if you're
following along so I'm going to do the
last fit give it the canine workflow and
then the tie a split okay now we're
going to use now we're gonna use the the
was at the tune package and basically
put them together so we'll say bind rows
will say boosted res mutate model equals
XE b and then we'll give it also the
canine rest mutate model equals can and
then we'll say on nest dot metrics and
we can see our was it where is it our
metrics for our models but what we
should actually use is oops nut we're
not gonna use it a tune pack we're going
to use the yardstick package sorry about
that
we're gonna use a yardstick package to
base the estimate our best models okay
so our estimate is very good for these
models however we can use the yardstick
to find the confusion matrix so we'll
look at our boosted razz will say well
on nest our dot predictions alright and
then we can do a confusion matrix so our
truth will be equal to our if we go back
here our species and our estimate equals
dot cred class
right and we can see it perfectly
predicted everything we can also do it
for our cannon recipe kn1 and we see
that it perfectly predict both in this
case I'm actually gonna just save the
model and I'm gonna just save the the
boosted model so what we're gonna do is
fit the entire data set using the model
the final workflow so I'm just want to
do I would say final boosted model using
that fit and we'll give it the boosted
workflow and our penguins data sets and
then I'm gonna save this model so final
boosted model - I'll say penguin model
RDS I'm actually going to make sure I
have my directory saved to the tight
Tuesday directory okay and I'll save it
cool so now I'm gonna save this one and
I'll put this in the tied Tuesday
penguins so tidy
Tuesday Penguins in England model great
so now I don't really need any of this
stuff anymore
and now we're gonna actually deploy this
model using a shiny app so I'll do a was
it a shiny web app we're gonna put this
into our tidy Tuesday and I'm what I'm
gonna call it as the tidy Tuesday
penguin app oops
oh yeah oops well open it that and we'll
call it my bad tidy Tuesday penguin app
okay I'm gonna go in
tidy Tuesday tie Tuesday I'm gonna put
the penguin model and tie your Tuesday
thing into our actual app and we're good
to go
so Oh actually I'm gonna make sure my
directory is in the tight the penguin
app okay Tuesday whereas tight cheese
that penguin app and I'll stay set as
working directory okay and what we're
gonna do is we're gonna load in the
shiny dashboard tidy models and the tidy
verse cool do that we'll do that right
there so we have that and what we're
also gonna do is we're gonna load into
our Mont load in a model so was a model
it's equal to read already yes penguin
was it model dot RTS so now we have our
model additionally what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna go back here and look up shiny
shiny dashboard okay see that get
started and I'm just gonna copy this
stuff in just so I don't have to retype
it out and I run into any issues do that
okay
library shiny okay so we're going to add
a title first so we're going to say
title equals penguin app okay and on our
sidebar we need sideboard sidebar we
need use a menu item and we're gonna
call this menu item penguin species
because our model will predict the what
penguin the species it what penguin
species the penguin belongs to sorry
about that
you got to give it a tab will get a
Pingo tab and the icon will give it a
snowflake icon I believe they have one
and what just run it so we're gonna run
it and we have a penguin species nothing
in here yet that's fine okay cool so
that's what we have right there now what
we're gonna do is we're actually add on
to a tab so we're gonna do that
so in our dashboard body we're gonna do
a tab item because this is going to be a
single page kind of a print of up the
tab name will be the penguin tab that we
gave it now we're gonna do is give it
some boxes so first what we're gonna do
is let's do all the inputs and if we
look at our model we can also look at
model pre what's at mall and was our
predictors we see we have all this stuff
right so what we're gonna do what we can
actually do maybe ago a few all right we
have our wheel a lot stuff so let's
first start putting in to all of our
values and in fact I'm just going to
call them names okay so in this case
we're gonna do box we're gonna do a
select input put it first and this input
ID will be V let's say Island okay
our label will be island because I want
to do all the categorical variables
first so which the island first and
there are choices our choices will
was it dream tour gerson and since it's
a dummy variable
oh we figure out which one it is so I'm
actually gonna do what see what what was
again let's hear penguins
it was library penguin just that well
what was it called again let me go back
[Music]
penguins data set
what was it called where's the island oh
well I'll just call it up so Palmer I'll
do also calling the poem penguins and
we'll say penguins select island
distinct oh oh is it Bisco so also its
go cool so that's our first one and now
we're going to do another one
in this case we're going to do was it V
sex so we'll say sex and I'll be what is
it if we do it sexes male and female
I'll just do mail email cool and then
what we're gonna do is a was it
slider input and now we can do column
names for that actually one one thing
what we should do is summary so now we
can actually kind of look at the the
kind of the range of numbers that it'll
be they'll be in so we'll say V the V
bill
length label equals bill length and
millimeters
our men will be 30 our max
oops our max will be is equal to let's
say 60 and our value will be the let's
just say the me D mean which will be 45
cool add a comb right there
did that instead they'll linked it will
be depth and we'll say depth and then it
was it man is 13 so it was a 10 hour max
of 21 will say 25 and a value will be 17
cool we'll do another one in this case
is it'll be flipper length so flipper
length look for length our men will be
say 170 our max will be say 235 and our
value will be 200 last two lastly we'll
do our body mass so body mass and this
will be body mass in grams
our main is 2700 will say that our max
is 6300 and our value that will be
choosing is 4,000 cool so let's run this
app to see if it works right now okay
and we have all of that it's working
pretty well what I'm going to do is I'm
going to capitalize some of these things
so sexy Island okay
and now what we're gonna do is we're
going to add in a value box
okay so box value box out output and
we'll say penguin prediction
okay and this is where we're actually to
apply this prediction okay so we'll say
was it output Dr penguin prediction
render value box okay so we already have
our model and we have our inputs what
we're going to do is run a creative
table so our table will be our island
which will be equal to input the island
I think we'll have a bill link in
millimeters which will be equal to input
the bill length we'll have a bill depth
in millimeters which will be input V
bill depth will do a flipper length
which we input the flipper length and
they won't have a was a body mass G I'm
going to do that mmm body mass and I'll
be equal to input V body mass C look at
a summary body mass G yes all that sense
and then we'll do our sex sex which is
equal to input V sex so we have our art
table and then we'll do a predict and
we'll give it our model and the table
that we created cool
okay so this is our prediction and this
will just give us the output that we
want from it okay so this will be a
prediction cool and now additionally
well I think is will be important is
we'll do the prediction prob in this
case we're just gonna use the same
function however after the tipple that
we made will say was it type equals prob
right and we'll just do and if we
actually look at this we do what is it
we we can kind of say a gap we we can do
a was it we can kind of look at what
it's doing so let's do that and what to
say
what is it input is uh this go
male and we'll just do I'm gonna
basically actually enter and some more
numbers so I'll do 20 20 20 20 and we'll
say type equals problem so what does it
do it actually gives out our
probabilities so what I think we should
do is gather it and then arrange by
descending value and then slice one
select value all right so that way we
have the value so that's what we're
going to do into this little change of
function right here cool and that'll be
our prediction probability additionally
I think it would be cool to change the
color so let's say prediction color and
we'll just do if else
so if else our prediction and if we
actually do the let me go back here we
remove type equals prob it actually just
gives us our dot pred class so we'll do
that dot pred class and we'll say it
equals what is it
England's select species distinct okay
so if we have if our class is equal to a
de lis we'll say a blue else if else
prediction cred class equals Gen 2 then
red else is yellow so just a nested if
statement for our prediction color now
finally we're gonna do our value value
box which is that our value will be
equal to our pace so we'll say paste 0
in this case I want to give it a
percentage so we'll give it the
prediction prob um and we know its value
so we'll say 100 times the prediction
value and we'll also round the round it
to a zero decimal places and give it a
percent then we'll do a subtitle
what's a paste 0 for species species and
we'll give it our was it prediction
prediction dot pred class alright dot
pride class value and then we'll do
lastly our actual do a color equals
prediction color and our icon will be
icon and we'll say snow plate just for
the same thing so let's see if it
actually runs and we'll do some tweaking
after prediction not found I spelled
prediction wrong pre pre diction okay
let's see if that runs prediction dick
predict up there the pre diction there
we go so now we can change it so we have
torgussen see how it changes to species
jen to italy change the island chinstrap
we also changed this thing
cool so you can see how it was actually
pretty simple to make this app I know
there's a pretty bare-bones app and you
could ever do a better UI but for me
when I'm doing deploying for models I
definitely prefer to put it in a shiny
web app over creating a restful api I
know this thing this tie trees it was
pretty fast I'm especially with the the
web app but I was basically just making
on basic filters and use those inputs
into our model and since our model is
just a XG boost model it predicts pretty
fast and you can do it in real time
and I'm sure you guys can build some
cool models and put do it and apply it
to your own project so I'm gonna end
this video and hopefully I'll see you
guys next week and Teddy on